hey guys to embarrass here author of
4-hour workweek for our this that and
the other thing tools of titans host of
the Tim Ferriss show all that and I want
to take a stab at a very common question
which is if you were starting a business
from scratch if you were starting a
podcast from scratch what advice would
you give well I will give you some
advice and I've thought about this a lot
and I've been asked this a lot and the
recommendations tend to be exactly the
same so first I would say that it is
easiest and in my mind much more fun to
create a category and own it as opposed
to trying to dominate an existing
category with something that is
incrementally better so if you try to
slot what you're going to do into a
pre-existing category and then beat the
best it is very hard to do that in
dramatic fashion and there are a few
homework assignments that I would
recommend you read immediately to really
hone in on how to think about this so
number one is a single chapter in a
single book is the law of category in a
book called 22 immutable laws of
marketing read that and if you're
thinking yourself I don't have time to
read books if you don't have time to
read two or three books that I am
recommending to you unless you have
built tons and tons of companies already
then you shouldn't build any companies
at all because you want to measure twice
and cut once when it comes to starting
businesses because you start a machine a
monster that you have to feed that is a
prison and is not something that derives
youth freedom then you are screwed and
it's going to be a lot harder to fix
after the fact so back to my point
number one the loft category chapter and
the 22 immutable laws of marketing
related to that and I would say 20 to 30
percent of this book is very very
interesting and will reinforce the same
idea which is blue ocean strategy or the
blue ocean strategy and you can
certainly look this up but the entire
book is worth reading I ended up somehow
reading it at Burning Man I have no idea
why it was there why
is reading a business book at burning it
for God's sake but it's probably because
there's 112 degrees in the afternoon but
I digress alright so that is the
importance of category creation or
category killing and then the very next
point we have is don't obsess on scaling
and becoming as big as possible alright
so I think it was oh I want to say it
was BJ Novak on the podcast famous for
the office an incredible writer in his
own right it might have been someone
else so feel free to jump in Adam and
correct me if I get this wrong but they
said if you if you work for the awards
your work will not be good but if you do
good work the awards will come so don't
worry about winning best of iTunes don't
worry about getting hundreds of millions
of downloads just do great work in a
category in a chosen product or service
or offering or type of writing that
makes you new alright and to do that
there are a few books that I would
recommend all right
so the the first and this is again
related to the question of scale so
scale and scaling are dangerous words
and sometimes you don't want to have a
gigantic business I certainly don't want
to have hundreds of thousands of
employees that I have to account for or
structure an org chart for or manage
those are not my core strengths nor
things that I enjoy so this book small
giants I think is worth visiting and
revisiting with subtitle this is the
suppose the gist
the main thrust companies that choose to
be great instead of big and this is by a
bow Burlingham this book talks about
companies that may in fact dramatically
constrain what they do to remain small
so maybe it's an artisan leather worker
who makes leather pants I'm serious this
is a real example and they and they make
perhaps a hundred pairs every year and
that's it if you want to buy from them
you need to be one of the hundred people
who reserve
parapets and among their clients are
people like shell crow and so on right
so they're able to build a fantastic
business maybe even a multi-million
dollar business that is constrained by
design so that they can have an ideal
lifestyle and life and craft a life not
just a business right so don't just
think how can I make the next unicorn to
use silly startup parlance or how can I
next time have a huge exit in 12 months
18 months more people are going to fail
with that type of objective at the
outset then people who set out to build
the best product possible whatever that
is that is easily differentiated easily
explained that scratches their own itch
so that's the next recommendation
scratch your own itch don't make
something for an imaginary or
hypothetical audience particularly one
that you don't really understand why
speaking as a 39 year old male who is
single am I going to make a podcast for
new mothers well I could but the
likelihood of it succeeding is very very
low
why don't I simply write the book that I
can't find for myself which is what I do
with 4-hour workweek or create things
that I can't find for myself say a
audiobook version of the letters of
Seneca which I did when I produced the
Tao of Seneca audio book series because
I wanted to exist now how many people
out there actually want to listen to
letters from philosopher who has been
dead for 2,000 years well I don't know
but I know the answer is at least one
and if I can get it excited about it and
I am excited about it I bet I can
convince other people to be excited
about it that's about as sophisticated
as the planning goes all right so
scratch your own itch and at the very
least you will end up with something
that you are proud of otherwise if you
build something for an imaginary
audience you will very often end up
something that doesn't please you that
you have to live with because you put it
out into the world and then you are
succeeding trying to be something other
than yourself in many cases very
compatible with that how big should your
business be how large does your
enterprise need to be to fuel your life
as it exists right now
it even let's say your full-time income
well you really only need one thousand
true fans and there's an essay called
one thousand true fans written by Kevin
Kelly founding editor of Wired magazine
an incredible technology futurist his
predictions are incredibly accurate and
have been for decades now he's written
an essay called 1000 treatments a
revised version of that is in tools of
titans my latest book also but i think
you can find both online now and the
general takeaway is that if you can find
if you can cultivate if you can target
and convert and proselytize a thousand
died hard vans these are your true fans
the people who will buy let's say in the
case of an author they will buy the
Kindle version they will buy the audio
version they will buy the updated and
expanded edition they will go to your
events they will effectively consume
anything that you put out because they
trust you up to that extent you don't
need to do anything else all right that
is all you need because they'll become
your strongest marketing force and they
will convert other concentric circles of
say from the true fans out to the semi
diehards out to the casual fans it all
radiates outward so 1,000 true fans I
think is a very measurable useful
heuristic to use when thinking about
building a business and it's very very
compatible with this right here so how
do you make decisions related to those
1,000 for fans well there are a few
different things you can do and I would
say that a lot of it comes down to being
very precise in your thinking and in
your objectives in German there is a
proverb it is very very German obvious
make the Moscow and C so that means
everything with measurement and
objective and if you want to succeed in
business if you simply have a easily
differentiated product you can explain
it simply you focus on 1,000 true fans
and you have clear measurable objectives
with check-ins say every week every
month every quarter or all the above to
track your performance and those key
performance indicators those key met
Ricks you are ahead of 99% of the world
who's trying to start a business and
people always talk about saying whatever
the number that's thrown around there's
so many made-up numbers like you need 8
ounces or 8 glasses of water a day who
came up with that there's no science
behind it you should drink water not
going to be wrong but then something
like 85 of allstar 85% of all Serbs fail
or 9 out of 10 startups fail whatever it
is most people who start businesses
shouldn't start businesses because they
do none of this planning maybe none of
this thinking they do none of this
differentiating or measuring all right
if you do those things I think you stand
at least a 50/50 chance if you actually
do the prep work in the training and
event so two books that I would
recommend and you could probably read
them in this order since one is shorter
than the other
this one right here is a gold mine this
is Peter Drucker's the effective
executive the definitive guide to
getting the right things done all right
this book forget about time management
you can fritter away hours and hours and
hours and hours days and days maybe in
weeks and weeks and months and months if
you get a few critical things done if
you are able to focus on the most
critical things often the most
uncomfortable things then you can
outpace everybody and/or just about
everybody the effective executive is
super short
it's an incredible read and you can see
I just have notes upon notes upon notes
related to this I reread this all the
time and it's critical because being
efficient doing something well doing
something quickly does not make it
important you can screw yourself by
doing a lot of unimportant things well
and that is one of the primary causes I
think for a lot of startup failure being
effective is doing the right things and
literally if you were to follow me
around and I very rarely have
journalists they follow me around that
they might propose doing a profile and
following me for a week they want to see
what you do and how you use your time
and they expect this well-oiled machine
that's making the best use of every
second like even if you were to talk to
the crew that's here helping filaments
right now they're gonna cough this guy's
like walking around as pajamas he's
taking 20 minutes go to the bathroom get
a glass of water like
this is the paragon of efficiency no I'm
not I'm actually focusing on being
effective
so by say filming what I'm filming right
now and doing this I'll have months and
months of content even if a kind of
screw around
I'm not the most well-oiled machine
today so the effective executive read
that and really instill it and memorize
as much of it as you can
the next is 8020 principle so I do talk
about this and the 4-hour workweek quite
a bit but be kind of cheesy for me to
recommend my own books I'm not going to
do that right now but the 8020 principle
the secret to success by achieving more
with less 8020 principle also known as
Pareto's law and this is the original
there are a number of books also by
Richard which are fantastic but the
original is very very strong and the
80/20 principle really people were for
doing different ways a power-law
distribution Zipf law is shorthand for
the rough observation that say in the
case of Pareto who is a economists and
sociologists 20% of the population and I
think it was Switzerland time possessed
80% or more of the wealth in that
country or it might have been region
similarly though he noticed that 20% of
say the pea pods or plants in his garden
produced 80% or more of the peas and you
could observe this very disproportionate
ratio of a small number of things
producing the vast majority of say
outcomes that you want or in the case of
obviously the sociological implications
of economics these disparities and you
can apply that to for instance
identifying after you've thrown a lot
against the wall so this will help you
to throw things against the wall as well
the other recommendations that I've made
and the first-time entrepreneur you
don't know what you're good at
you don't know what people are going to
like really and so you throw a bunch
things against Floyd try a bunch of
different types of advertising you try a
bunch of different explanatory messaging
maybe so you have text on the website
try bunch split test etcetera and then
eventually start figuring out what kind
of works once you get to that point then
let's say you have a thousand
and you're burning midnight oil oh my
god this thing I thought was going to
save me from my nine-to-five now I'm
working 18 hours a day what do I do
well one of the first steps you could
take which is what I took is looking at
your customers and identifying the 20%
of customers that are producing 80% or
more of your revenue and it could be
that 5% producing 95% the it doesn't
have to add up to 100
right but conversely if you look at the
20% of customers that consume 80% or
more of your time and what you may find
very often you'll find is that the most
lucrative customers the ones you should
be cultivating that you should be
modeling so you can target similar
customers are those that take very
little time and that the squeaky wheels
the ones that you're spending so much
time on are in fact only contributing
five ten percent to the bottom line and
even if they contribute more what if you
fired on one or two of those customers
would allow you to replicate these low
maintenance high-yield customers and
this can be applied a million different
ways so the 80/20 principle and then the
last one I'm going to mention because
it's very easy to lose sight of why you
started so we talked about small giants
we talked about blue ocean strategy we
talked about all of that you may find
yourself at some point a year in two
years in 10 years in who knows where you
sit back and you look at your life and
you say this is not what I wanted when I
started on this journey building this
company or taking the side gig becoming
freelance or whatever it might be at
that point if you need a recalibration
if you feel like there is a gear shift
needed then this book which is one I
traveled with in 2004 there are two
books I had Walden by Thoreau now this
one vagabonding by Rolf Potts and I've
given away dozens maybe hundreds of this
book and the subtitle is an uncommon
guide to the art of long term world
travel but vagabonding is not about
travel per se in my opinion it is about
philosophy and is about thinking about
materialism is it is about examples and
case studies of people who have
experimented
we're doing the opposite of mores more
reducing their possessions utilizing
time instead of money building that
currency etc vagabonding is a a great
way to create some wanderlust and desire
to adventure in yourself it is also I
think a very helpful course correction
if you found yourself trying to keep up
with the Joneses or build a company for
the sake of building a company and if
you're simply working to make something
bigger without much thought to say
balance in your life relationships or
adventure and it's just about adding a
few more dollars to the bank account
every day or week then vagabonding if
you want to create a business from
scratch at some point it will be less
than scratch if you follow the
instructions we have up to this point
and almost certainly we all lose our way
and we get distracted we might be pulled
off course by some shiny objects and
your job in that case because it happens
to everyone is to have a means of
correcting your course direction and one
of the tools I use is vagabonding by
Ross Potts and last but not least I will
say that the objective of 4-hour work
week and everything that I've ever
talked about is not idleness I don't
promote violence I have nothing wrong
with hard work as long as that hard work
is applied to the right areas as long as
you have a clear target and you have
your site and your scope very well
calibrated so that you are hitting with
a high ratio of success I have no
problem with hard work and I tend to be
either on or off if you are on all the
time and you are hustling 24/7 in a very
scatterbrained fashion that in itself is
a form of laziness indiscriminate action
is reflective of too little thinking and
planning and that is lazy and it's one
of the most destructive forms of
laziness because it is socially
reinforced and people will encourage you
to do that in other words they will say
don't just stand there do something well
if you're constantly doing things that
are not carefully thought through you
will end up doing the opposite of the
80/20 principle you will end up
specializing in unimportant things
you'll become an expert in doing the
things that are trivial well
and that is a travesty in this huge
waste of life so work hard I've no
problem with that but only when it is
applied to the right things so
everything we've measured it and
objective like I said earlier pick up
these books revisit them often as I do
and I think that you can dramatically
improve the chances of your success and
fulfillment when you want to build a
business write a book a podcast or
anything else so good luck if you
enjoyed this video I want to propose you
check out the podcast the Tim Ferriss
show why is it been number one on iTunes
across all categories in some cases
number one in business why does it have
70 million plus downloads because I
interview world-class performers from
athletics business and includes
billionaires from everything imaginable
entertainment to tease out the routines
the habits the tools that you can use so
check it out the Tim Ferriss show